ce soir on va se faire tout petit et
plongée dans le monde des matériaux
minuscule les nanomatériaux ou plus
précisément des cristaux infiniment
petit les nanos cristaux je vais vous
faire découvrir comment c'est grâce à
cette liste au interagissent avec la
lumière et je vais vous expliquer
comment il arrive à changer la couleur
de celle ci il y a rien de magique là
dessus mais seulement des propriétés
exceptionnelles de ces matériaux qui
vont sûrement servir à développer les
technologies du futur
par exemple prenons votre téléphone
portable ou votre tablette
si on y jette un coup d'oeil derrière sa
coque qu'est ce qu'on y voit
on y voit des composants qui vont servir
a par exemple enregistré les données par
la nouvelle photo que vous avez prises
et pour amener la formation à ses
composants il y a un nombre important de
fils de métal qui vont conduire
l'électricité par pulsions électriques
vers ses composants et ses fils de métal
il se comporte avec l'électricité
subissent des landes père thermique si
bien que si on les compare à une
conduite d'eau on verrait à peu près ça
dans votre téléphone portable
donc on peut bien imaginer que c'est pas
la technologie idéale pour économiser
l'énergie
si bien que si on pouvait remplacer ses
fils de cuivre ou ses fils métalliques
par des fils de lumière
on pourrait alors là éviter toutes les
pertes thermiques duales électricité
puisqu'on ne ferait circuler plus des
électrons mais des photons de la lumière
pour aller enregistrer l'information
plus rapidement en économisant l'énergie
est aussi sans avoir besoin ensuite de
recharger votre natel tous les soirs où
stocker de plus en plus de photos vous
surfez plus vite on vous allez me dire
mon téléphone portable déjà trop rapide
pour moi donc ça ne m'intéresse pas mais
je vais vous donner un autre exemple qui
est un peu plus vital puisqu'il est
lié à notre santé et ces particules dont
je vous parle
elles peuvent servir aussi comme
matériau de contraste c'est à dire ce
qui est utilisée lorsque vous allez
faire une image au scanner on va d'abord
vous injectez en matin les contrastes
que les images médicales sont beaucoup
plus claires et précises mais pour
ensuite faire l'image au scanner et
utiliser ce sont des rayons x et ses
rayons x en lisant c'est à dire qu'ils
vont interagir avec tous les tissus qui
sont avant le matériau qui va être
utilisée ensuite pour imager votre
organe ou quelque chose d'autre
donc si on utilise un autre type de
matériau ce qui va être possible c'est
d'utiliser non pas des rayons x nocifs
mais une seule lampe infrarouge la même
que j'ai vu pour réchauffer l'apéro ou
celle qui est utilisée pour réchauffer
les poussins ou les nourrissons sur leur
table à langer donc des rayons
absolument inoffensif je vous parle de
ces particules mais de quoi ont-elles
l'air en voici un exemple au microscope
électronique
on voit qu'elles sont plus ou moins sept
éric elles ont été synthétisés
chimiquement
elles sont composées d'un métal et d'un
oxyde et la fabrication est assez simple
et qu'est ce qui se passe lorsqu'on les
illumine avec une lumière infrarouge
mais se passe rien du tout parce qu'en
fait la technologie n'est pas encore
assez développé pour pouvoir utiliser
une lumière aussi simple c'est pour ça
que dans mon laboratoire on utilise à
laser ce laser relativement puissant il
ne va pas
et détruire aux cellules si bien qu'on
va pouvoir aussi vous utilisez vous
faire de l'imagerie médicale
et qu'est ce qui se passe quand ces
particules vendait rim illuminée par
cela vers elles vont devenir bleu
comment ça se fait essayons de regarder
une celle ci qu'est-ce qui si on la
regarde plus précisément au microscope
électronique
ce qu'on va voir même avec un microscope
avec une haute résolution qu'elles ont
un arrangement très précis de leurs
atomes
elles ont une symétrie très précise avec
au centre aussi un atom légèrement
asymétrique et grâce à cette légère
asymétrie lorsque le laser va illuminer
la particule il va pouvoir
elle va pouvoir émettre une lumière
bleue bleus mais pourquoi bleus et ça
s'explique par le comportement de la
lumière le comportement de la lumière
par exemple la lumière blanche qui nous
arrive du soleil lorsqu'il traverse
les gouttelettes d'eau après une courte
pli elle est composée de toutes les
lignes de toutes les couleurs de l'arc
en ciel allant du bleu en passant par le
vert le jaune et ensuite le rouge et
cette lumière comment se comporte elle
est comment se déplacent tel se déplace
comme une vague
et vu qu'en physique on est politique on
appelle ça une onde et s'étendent plus
on se déplace vers le rouge
et plus elle est longue et c'est
exactement londe qu'on utilise pour
illuminer ses particules rouge
infrarouge pourquoi rouge infrarouge
parce que vu que cette onde est très
longue
elle va non seulement pouvoir traverser
la peau mais elle ban pas être diffusée
par tous les tissus qui sont entre la
source de lumière et les particules qui
auront été injectés pour faire l'image
donc un avantage grand avantage et qui
on compare ensuite à la lumière émise
qui est bleu à 120 à ce moment lalonde
est très courte
si on si on divise londe rouge parlons
de leurs remarques c'est exactement un
facteur 2 donc elle est deux fois plus
longue dans le rouge que dans le bleu et
on n'est pas limité à cette couleur pas
si on change la source
on prend une source encore plus
infrarouge ce qui va être encore moins
diffusés dans le tissu et va pouvoir
images et jusqu'à vos poumons par
exemple on va alors avoir une réponse de
cette onde dans le vert ou une toute
autre couleur suivant qu'on va utiliser
une autre longueur d'onde et cette
couleur elle elle peut permettre de
faire une maj rit aussi profondément
possible et si on veut pousser
l'analogie du poète vers la musique
ce conte aussi un peu musicien on peut
dire que l'effet de transformer la
lumière rouge en lumière bleue c'était
la génération de la deuxième harmonique
donc la première à monique ce serait la
nôtre fondamentale et si on se déplace
de cette touche on tente sur la 2ème
harmonique et c'est la même chose pour
la musique que pour les couleurs et est
ce que ça marche
ben oui ça m'a on a injecté ces
particules sous la peau du souris qui
est en train de dormir gentiment son
microscope est là qu est ce qu on voit
on voit que les particules ici
légèrement allongées situé sous la peau
sont très lumineuses dans ce que je vous
dis pas la sec en fait ces particules à
se trouve très très proche de la surface
donc à peine 1 millimètre sous la peau
impossible donc de d'imagés à ce moment
là des cellules qui se trouveraient très
profondément encore comme des organes
comme les poumons
c'est pourquoi le défi de marcheurs
c'est de trouver d'abord un matériau qui
est assez brillant ensuite un matériau
qui est assez petit pour pouvoir image
est aussi profondément que possible et
aussi précisément que possible et quand
je dis petit qu'est ce que j'entends par
là donc si je reprends la particule au
microscope électronique et que je la
compare à un cristal que vous auriez
trouvé pas serment cherchant au pied
d'un glacier elles ont à peu près la
même structure un oxyde de métal et
du point de vue de la grandeur par
contre c'est bien différent parce que ce
cri sales cloud 2 cm il est un million
de fois plus grand que cette particule à
millions de fois on pense que c'est déjà
bien assez petit mais non parce que si
j'aimerais image et une cellule
cancéreuse d'un poumon avec cette
particule qu'est-ce qui se passe la
particule est à peu près aussi grosse
que cette balle de tennis est le poumon
ou la cellule serait imagé par la main
donc image et une main avec une balle de
tennis je pourrais même pas vous dire
combien vous avez deux doigts donc
inutile pour cette application
donc non seulement on doit réduire la
taille des particules pour pouvoir faire
des images très précises mais aussi on
ne doit pas l'église et la brillance de
la particule parce qu'en réduisant sa
taille on réduit sa brillance si bien
que nous développons des stratégies pour
augmenter la brillance de ces particules
est une des stratégies c'est de
recouvrir cet oxyde de métal d'un autre
métal
ici vous le voyez en anthracite ce sont
de minuscules particules d'or et si
minuscules particules d'or
elles vont permettre de concentrer la
lumière rouge dans le coeur de la
particule qui va pouvoir ensuite émettre
dans le bleu à des brillances à peu près
1000 fois plus élevé que ce qu'on a déjà
mesuré sur des particules qui ne sont
pas recouvertes d'or est ce qui est
intéressant de pouvoir recouvrir les
particules d'or c'est qu'elle devienne
aussi baïocco biocompatible c'est à dire
qu'on va pouvoir les orienter
directement sur des cellules cancéreuses
et pouvoir non seulement faire un
diagnostic exact de la cellule à
éliminer mais aussi une thérapie en
utilisant les démissions d'autres
couleurs que le rouge ou que le bleu
c'est à dire aller jusque dans
l'ultraviolet où le rayon x qui est
nocif et qui va détruire seulement la
cellule qu'il va falloir éliminer
je vous ai parlé d une application
médicale très attractive
j'aimerais revenir à ma première
application pour l'informatique
et là on ne va pas utiliser des
particules il on va utiliser des fils
des fils qui ont cet ept
et qu'est-ce qu'ils ont de particulier
c'est qu'il peut guider la lumière mais
vous allez me dire ça existe déjà la
fibre optique
oui mais la fibre optique elle va guider
la lumière de l'autre côté de l'océan
pour vous puissiez surfer sur un site
qui est localisée à l'autre bout de la
terre et 7 la particularité d'une fibre
optique c'est qu'elle est grande comme
on veut et elle est très très longue et
elle n'est pas il n'est pas possible de
l'intégrer très facilement à aux
circuits imprimés que je vous ai montré
qu'ils se situent dans votre téléphone
portable votre tablette
si bien que les fils que nous étudions
ils ont un diamètre 100 fois plus petit
que la fibre optique donc 100 fois plus
petit que vos cheveux
ils ont une longueur de quelques
millimètres et ça suffit pour guider la
lumière sur un circuit imprimé
est ce que ça marche à peu près ici vous
montre qu'on arrive à coupler la lumière
à l'intérieur de ce fil mais il ya
d'énormes pertes dans ce couplage on
arrive à guider la lumière puisqu'ils si
vous voyez un tout petit parti bleu est
absolument aucune perte donc comparé au
fil de cuivre qui comme ma conduite
d'eau fuis fuis thermiquement énormément
on arrive déjà à éliminer ce genre de
fuites mais vu comme vous le voyez c'est
pas encore gagné donc je vais retourner
à lemont lavaud et je vous laisse passer
une belle soirée